là où ça bouge nous sommes au frac
normandie caen qui dans le cadre de
normandie impressionniste accueille une
grande artiste contemporaine
elle s'appelle orlan elle a fait de son
corps n'a remet à la fois politique et
artistique
l'exposition s'intitule orlan today à
découvrir absolument
dans les années 90 l'artiste française
défraie la chronique artistique en
scénarisant ses opérations de chirurgie
esthétique
sous anesthésie elle lit des textes
pendant que le chirurgien modifie son
corps sa particularité travailler sur
son corps en effet qu'elle considère
comme un instrument politique notamment
féminisme totalement toutes les
questions d'identité qui sont apparues
au fil du temps dans les années 80 les
années 70 avec le féminisme à la pointe
de ce ces revendications et ce travail
spécifique est liée à ça sur le corps le
slogan féministe de l'époque c'était
notre corps nous appartient
orlan today ce sont les nouvelles
technologies ici dans l'exposition on a
plusieurs exemples d'idées avec elle le
réalise en ce moment même
elles sont à la pointe scientifiques
aussi elle a dépassé la peau donc il ya
une oeuvre lycée qui s'appelle écorché
l'écorché est en effet c'est un écorché
en avatar où on voit cet avatar se
déplacer et se transformer en statue de
la liberté
parlant to death est à découvrir au frac
normandie caen jusqu'au 20 août
orlan reviendra à caen en l'église saint
sauveur en juin prochain pour présenter
sa vision des jeux numériques
nous vous en reparlerons bien sûr
les élèves du collège lechanteur deux
camps se mobilisent pour emeline la
jeune collégienne de cresserons est
encore hospitalisé à l'hôpital necker de
paris et son retour à la maison
nécessite de trouver des fonds donc
demain soir à 20h quand vous irez au
concert au bbc d'hérouville saint clair
pour écouter les school of rock et 20
vous ferez une bonne action
là où ça bouge au bord de l'orne dans le
val de mezze avec les collégiens de
guillaume de normandie qui tourne un
film intitulé la catapulte paris et toi
tu va tourner le miroir vers vers le
truc dehors là de manière à ce qu elle
soit obligé de venir vers l'objectif de
sortir par ici on y va il sort en fait
c'est un gardien qui est il ya une porte
entre le dedans et le dehors et ils
veulent rentrer dans le dedans et ils
sont catapultés parce qu'ils ont tous un
défaut et on se retrouve tout ce temps
le dehors
l'idée c'est donc de parler de quoi
c'est quoi le sur le sujet de fond de la
discrimination la discrimination c'est
parce qu'on est différent qu'on peut pas
rentrer dans le dedans c'est ça l'idée
vous vous êtes tout les toutes les
personnes soit été catapulté avant ce
qu'on a catapulté alors les adultes qui
se sont occupés du film
les voilà alors on a travaillé sur
l'écriture pendant les heures de vie de
classe c'est à dire une heure quinzaine
à partir d'un scénario que laurent avait
lui même proposé c'est à dire que les
élèves ont rajouté des péripéties ils
ont modifié la fin mais c'était à partir
du scénario que l'on nous avait donné
moi ta leur silence action deux jours il
lui faut qu'on est touché et il ya quand
même pas mal de boulot avec des petits
acteurs qui pour beaucoup sont son
snobisme donc voilà mais on s'en sort il
nous reste une demi journée on va y
arriver et donc vous vous venez
d'entendre vous venez d'entendre le beau
le boum quand il vient d'arriver
vous venez d'entendre le gros boum quand
il ya sindia d'arrivée il est passé tout
là haut il a atterri ici et vous vous
savez vous est tous passés par là donc
vous êtes même plus étonné de voir
arriver quelqu'un vous regardez juste
qui arrive donc vous êtes complètement
blasé est-ce que c'est difficile de
jouer sans paroles
c'est plus facile bas d'un côté c'est
plus facile parce qu'il n'y a pas de
choses à apprendre mais après il faut
vraiment réussir avec les gestes à on va
dire avec les expressions à transmettre
un message fort fait normalement
production au collège au mois de juin
soit pas trop la tête encore et puis on
aimerait bien qu'ils aient une
projection si au luxe à samedi matin
pour les enfants et les jeunes et les
parents des familles donc ça s'appelle
la catapulte et en espèrent bien le voir
au luxe c'est un appel aux gens du luxe
mais je voulais faire une petite
dédicace
ouais alors enfin on est presque vallée
debica je suis désolé parce que sinon
tout le monde en est à ma maman
j'oubliais merci